hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled
panel presentation overcoming challenges
of copy number variant interpretations
with qci interpret and the acmg
guidelines for cnbs this webinar is part
of the clinical diagnostics and research
event and i'm susie valdez of labyrinths
and i will be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labries and sponsored by
kyogen for more information about our
sponsor please visit them at kyogen.com
so let's get started before we begin i
want to remind everyone that this event
is interactive and we encourage you to
first participate by communicating with
other attendees using our new live chat
feature
used during the presentation you can
find that live chat feature located at
the right of your screen you can also
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during this
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation just click on
the help desk button located at the
bottom of your screen where the
navigation bar is and from the lobby and
finally as a reminder the presentation
is educational and offers free
continuing education credits click on
the continuing education credits tab
located at the abstract window below the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain those credits i now
present today's speakers dr dan richards
the vice president of global clinical
product management at kyogen digital
insights and dr martin jones the
scientific product owner at kyogen
digital insights for a complete
biography of our presenters please visit
the biography tab at the left of your
screen dr richards dr jones welcome you
may now begin your presentation
hello everyone i would like to welcome
you to the cajun digital insights
webinar on overcoming challenges of copy
number variation interpretation with qci
interpret my name is marianne and i'll
be the host and moderator for today's
webinar
now i would like to introduce our
speakers for today dr martin jones and
dr dan richards
dr martin jones is a global product
owner for clinical decision support
software and interpretation services at
kyogen digital insights
dr dan richards is the vice president of
global clinical product management for
pyogen digital insights where he focuses
on the automated interpretation of
molecular variation in the context of
current clinical evidence thank you for
joining us today martin and dan i'll now
hand the presentation over to you
thanks
hello i'm dan richards i had a clinical
product management and
touch on some of the
capabilities our hygiene clinical
insight interpret product can
provide to help
overcome the challenges of copy number
variation interpretation
i'd like to start with just a brief
introduction to kaijan digital insights
that's a group of um several hundred
scientists as well as hundreds of
engineers and other specialists
that work daily to
keep on top of the new
clinical literature and and provide
products that help translate genomic
data into
clinical insights or actionable insights
we have a variety of products in
different areas from
academic research
on human samples all the way to clinical
laboratory testing
and one of the core things we do is
curate this evidence from the scientific
literature keep it up to date for you so
you can get a constant
current view of what's known to be
clinically relevant
and gain insights into your data we have
over 90 000 customers worldwide
our product's been cited over 35 000
publications and the particular product
i'll talk about today kaijen clinical
insight interpret has been used to
interpret over 2 million patient samples
today
since this knowledge base that we
created is so core to our products and
i'll talk about today i just want to
touch a little bit on
our process
so our curation
sort of like a factory-like process it's
high scale we have hundreds of
scientists working on the curation uh
it's systematic it goes through a
curation of protocols and processes that
are rigorously tested and defined and
that provides very high quality
computable evidence that then can be
used
to
put the data that is generated
from next generation sequencing for
example into context of
what's currently known about the
variance or alterations detected for
example
we curate a variety of different sources
of course scientific literature all the
major journals but we also
curate medical guidelines like practice
guidelines drug labels integrated
various other
databases are commonly used as well as
molecular data sets
in clinical trials as well so it's a
wide variety of different content
sources that are
clinically uh relevant that we curate on
a daily basis and that is done through a
distributed workforce of scientists that
are trained on the various protocols we
use and read the literature or review
the other sources and integrate it into
our what we call the kaijan knowledge
base which then enables our various
applications to compute over it and take
data that you may generate and put it
into biological context for you
and so over the past 20 years we've
curated over 20 million
findings as we call them and i'll just
show an example what what that is it's
sort of every everything we curate is
fully transparently tied back to the
source that we curated it from
uh so in this case this is uh some
example what we call variant findings
from this particular article that you
know show
various details in terms of whether
mutations germline and what the
translation is the disease association
the population observed uh with the the
mutation variation
whether it's childhood adults a wide
variety of details that uh when they're
present or captured in our curation
process and this evidence enables us to
map for example this finding if it
appears in in a sample
you run through kaijen clinical insight
for instance to
be matched to it and provide insight
into
case reports for example
so hygiene clinical insight interpret if
your
first time hearing about it i just want
to give a brief introduction to it as
well
it's our premier clinical interpretation
and reporting
tool
it's an application that's web
based so you sort of upload your data
through apis or or user interface into
qci
and then you
analyze it if you're using doing
translational research or if you're a
clinical lab doing a laboratory
developed test you can use it for
clinical decision support
and sort of
review the variance in a test in the
context of qci
what's core to it is it's evidence-based
software it takes those uh variant
findings that evidence we curate i
mentioned
into account computationally
and then assists in your review of the
alterations or variants you detect in in
any particular sample
to enable you to assess which ones are
clinically significant
and if you're using a clinical decision
support version of qci interpret
report out
create final reports as needed so
according to what we provide is this
comprehensive annotation a literature
resource
so
we have all kinds of information about
case reports and
functional studies
frequency in the general population and
in a somatic cancer context this is also
applicable it helps identify
what treatments may be available
clinical trials are currently available
in a particular location prognosis and a
variety of other information as well
so we really try to provide a
comprehensive view for for human samples
what
which variants are clinically actionable
and in what ways
too
and this is done in a very scalable
automated way so we provide
out-of-the-box alignment of our content
with professional guidelines i'll touch
on that a little bit more here but it
basically enables all the variants you
detect immediately get dynamically
classified based on the uh acmg
guidelines for germline variants or the
amp guidelines for cancer or somatic
variants
so that you can immediately identify
which ones are are perhaps most
clinically relevant to review and
potentially include on report
and that can be done at scale since we
cover uh all the routinely commonly uh
clinically tested genes for herreratory
disease as well as cancer as well as
have full hdmd integration
within qci interpret sort of cover sort
of the whole exome
in their ability to put variants into
biological context and
provide insight into which are
potentially
disease-causing or disease promoting
for cancer workflows we also provide
actionability in terms of defining which
treatments and clinical trials
given the patient's gender and age and
other considerations diagnosis of tumor
are
are relevant for that particular case
right out front
automatically
and we provide customized reporting too
so some of our our
customers they have their own they use
qci fully for producing final signed
reports there's a whole workflow support
integration as well in terms of multiple
levels of review if desired and a lab
director sign out with the digital
signature
support full lims integration
as well through apis
and two so
a whole product over here just to put in
the context is really
focused on not secondary analysis but
for the interpretation reporting part of
the overall workflow for genomic data
interpretation whether it be germline or
cancer somatic samples that you're
reviewing
so
briefly again what we provide with our
curated evidence is the ingredients so
to speak for
assessing
the clinical significance of variants
and we assess the clinical significance
of variants in the germline context
using the amp guidelines which puts
every variant in a category from benign
pathogenic
for somatic cancer variants we
also have the actionability aspect which
provides the tiering
in terms of for that particular mutation
that particular diagnosis
tumor type
you know what how actionable
is it for a patient in terms of
treatment trials or prognostic
significance for instance
so again all this information we
constantly curate on a daily basis in
knowledge base powers the ability for us
to apply algorithms that use these
guidelines as frameworks to
automatically
provide an up-to-date computed
classification
in both these senses
for your variants that you detect in
having your samples that you upload into
the system for example in variant call
file format
and lets you quickly triage them and
identify which may be relevant uh
for your
reviewer reporting purposes
so one touch now on copy number
variation
overall and so we dig deeper into what
qci does particularly for copy number
variation there's quite a variety of
things that gave you a quick flavor of
some of the things it does but
today's focus really is on
what qti provides to assist in assessing
copy number variation
um
so
just putting things in perspective the
whole field of cytogenetics has evolved
quite a bit over the last 20 years from
you know
fish to chromosomal microarray or array
comparative genomic hybridization
approaches
and now a lot of folks are using ngs for
detecting copy number aberrations
the reason ngs is is particularly useful
is it can detect things
that are small copy number variations so
by copy number variation i mean both
deletions are part of a chromosomal
region or of a chromosomal region like a
either axon level deletion
or a whole gene deletion or it could be
you know a large chunk of a chromosome a
cytogenic deletion as well
ngs can help detect all of those types
of chromosomal aberrations
uh it has some advantages over mlpa it's
sort of pcr-based for example methods
since it can be applied to many genes in
a panel or all the exons of many genes
in the panel at once whereas mlpa is
more tailored to particular axons it's
not that scalable so many labs use ngs
and if there's a copy number detection
in ngs can
always confirm with mlpa for example and
likewise relatively older chromosome
microarray ngs panels
sort of provide a deeper level of
resolution than chromosome microarray
can unless you have a very customized
design
so ngs avoids the need to create a lot
of customized
probes and there's a limitation of probe
placement for microarrays of course
based on which variants are polymorphic
in the general population so ngs
provides much more data it can provide
very precise endpoints of deletions or
duplications of genes
and that's valuable because it increases
the diagnostic yield
that the assay can provide so not only
can it provide a simpler workflow than
using mlpa
for example on a routine basis it also
can provide a more simpler and cost
effective workflow with a higher
diagnostic yield which is what we all
want for
our patients benefit
so the
american college of medical genetics
recently
provided new guidelines
to interpret copy number variation so
you know both for cytogenetic
laboratories that work uh
on chromos with chromosome like array
and ray cgh among other methods on a
routine basis
many laboratories have also adopted
next-generation sequencing and both of
them since they both can detect uh copy
number changes
want to make sure there's consistency in
terms of how those copy number changes
are are clinically assessed
and so through a wide variety of
participants the american college
medic
medical genetics and genomics and the um
also with the clint gen
funded research sort of got folks
together to identify
how to go about
in a consistent way assessing the
clinical significance of copy number
variants
and they came up with these guidelines
which are intended to be used both for
cytogenetic or array cgh chromosome
microarray detected cmvs as well as for
angiospec stratus sort of standardized
interpretation
uh in the field
along with that publication they provide
this uh as you see on the right here of
what's called the clingen cmv
pathogenicity calculator which if you're
not a familiar with these guidelines can
give you a sense of you know there's
about 80 or so different considerations
or questions that it goes through to
help
determine a final assessment the overall
assessment ends up in the same acmg
framework from benign to pathogenic
so you can get pathogenic likely
pathogenic buffs or likely benign or
benign of course
and these guidelines are for
hereditary or germline cnb
interpretation only just to be clear
so
what does qci interpret do for copy
number variant interpretation there's
many things but there's sort of three
things i want to highlight today
one is
to provide
supporting literature content uh in the
we have a bibliography feature in this
application
uh and
that supporting literature content
addresses the need of
determining whether a similar cnv has
been reported in
another patient in the literature
um
so the need here is you know really
understanding whenever you get one of
these copy number variants without
matching them to some other evidence
that they've been seen in another
patient or having some really strong
first principles reason
uh such as a full gene deletion that the
copy number variant is going to affect
function
it's good to have the supporting
literature to understand
is there a case in the literature which
has
overlapping very similar cmv
typically they're not going to be
identical
and if so does that patient or those
patients report in literature do they
have similar symptoms with
for with the patient you may be
assessing
the sample of at hand
the second area is this new acmg cmv
guidelines sort of automatically
computing pathogenicity based on them
and this is more of a triage need if
you're doing an exome or whole genome
which are translational version of qci
interpret many of the customers
use
certain exomes and genomes
you have this need where you have
your pipeline may detect many copy
number variations at the smaller exon
level scale
and uh
whether they're
exon deletions or partial gene deletions
or amplifications
duplications of gene regions
it can be challenging to figure out
which of those uh are most likely
pathogenic and so the guidelines give a
principled way to automatically classify
all those based on the current evidence
and knowledge we have about those genes
so that when you look at your sample
with these many cmv
variants called you immediately you can
see the the ones that appear to be
likely pathogenic or pathogenic at the
top of
the list of variants for example when
you look at a
sample or case in qci interpret
and the third area is aside from the
published literature which we curate the
acmg guidelines which we dynamically
compute and provide to triage your
variants is ability to link to
unpublished data so there's a variety of
excellent
databases out there that have gathered
copy number variant reports some in the
literature but often many not
such as decipher that you want to that
we provide the ability to link out to to
review the evidence to look at the cases
in those external databases to
understand likewise is a similar cnv in
a patient does it exist and what's known
about that patient even if they're not
in the published literature we curate
i'll go through each of these a little
more detail um but i
sort of wanted to start with the
highlights
and also uh before getting into more
detail there just touch a little bit on
the workload so we're all oriented
um in particular
what we provide with qci interpret and
then translational is the academic
research edition the other additions are
for clinical decision support and
laboratory developed test purposes
is a flexible and scalable
evidence-based variant interpretation
platform so
it is focused primarily on variants from
next generation sequencing although it
can be adapted to
microarray
cmds as well
but whether you use a kaijen kaiseek
panel or
any vendor's assay as chemistry it sort
of supports them all hygiene
digital insights offers a product called
clc genomics workbench which has nice
integration with qci interpret does the
secondary analysis of
any panel the so speak or genome or exo
assay
and translates it into the variance and
copy number alterations as well that are
are detected in the sample
but you can use any secondary analysis
with qci interpret so
sort of support
all vendors and and public uh
pipelines through the standard of the
varankhal file format which is the input
into qci interpret along with some
metadata about the sample uh either
entered through the ui or send along
with the vcf through the apis
so then qci interpret does this
filtering it does the variant
classification
helps put things in the biological
context and can get you to that final
report or export from an api to
integrate to your limbs to produce your
own report
so along this workflow workflow i just
give an example here um
for everybody your edification is that
there's the clc genomics workbench has
this tool that detects copy number
variation
uh and a way one way to think about it
is generally these uh the way uh
informatically these uh copy number
variants are detected as
you have a set of baseline samples which
i believe are normal abnormal
or diploid
two chromosome copies for each each
sample sequence a bunch of those in your
environment
and then you use that as a baseline to
then train
on the software here in this case
genomics workbench to identify
what is the statistically significant
decrease which would be a copy number or
loss or a region of the genome that's
deleted or statistically significant
increase which would typically
correspond to a tandem duplication or
duplication of some sort of the gene
um
for germline samples
and then the output of this collar which
then detects sort of the using window
approach uh if typically the um
endpoints exact endpoints are not known
if you're using a panel or exome
clinical exome chemistry because the
intronic regions where often these
endpoints fall for these chromosomal
region deletions or
duplications don't have data for those
non-sequenced areas of the genome so
often there's a windowing approach that
helps determine uh across an axon or
part of an axon is there a higher lower
signal that does significantly uh
different and consistent with a change
in the overall
chromosomal copy number of that region
so those baseline samples the algorithms
and the secondary analysis then produce
these copy number calls which are then
sent on
for example in this case
of baraka 1 copy number variation
exon 22 deletion from the
upstream secondary analysis software
through vcf to qci interpret
via in this case uh upload to qci
interpret tools so there's api
integration that can can get samples uh
to qci interpret directly
uh so then this this gives you a first
glance at some of the qci interpret how
copy number variants are displayed so if
they're exon level it'll tell you which
exon in the genes deleted or duplicated
for example
it'll show you the the relevant acmg cmv
classification in the assessment window
at the top when you're looking at the
details of a variant
and then there's this bibliography
feature which
when you click on that it brings up the
supporting literature uh for this the
particular variant you're looking at
as well
and this assessment is also computed
and shown in the top and right in terms
of what it nets out is it likely
pathogenic or benign or what have you it
sort of provides that visibility uh
immediately up front in the top of the
window
so touch on a few more
aspects the copy number variation can be
quite um complex i want to share a
little bit about
uh
some of the things that qci does to to
simplify it for you and streamline your
interpretation workflow
um so one of the needs is there
can be multiple um
multiple exons uh called within the same
gene so imagine you know if you
if you have whole genome data for
example maybe on the left side of the
slide here
you might have a
a
call since you have
genomic data for every
base in the genome conceptually
it can detect the precise endpoints of a
deletion let's say so in this mock up on
g1 you have exon four and five uh it may
have you know part of the intronic
sequence the left of exon four to the a
little bit of the introns that sequence
the end of x on after the exon 5 and it
can know that whole chromosomal range is
missing
because it just sees the junction
between to the left of x on 4 and to the
right x on 5 and they can call a
copy number loss with you know precision
and that's fine that this
you know folks doing whole genome
sequencing with structural iron colors
that produce input like that are fully
supported in qci that you know would
just be displayed as an exon four to
five deletion um and that uh you know
enables
um uh clarity in terms of the span of
these large copy number alterations
uh most people though are using panels
or exomes on galaxone sequencing and
there you don't have intronic uh
information you don't have any data for
the intron so you just have data for the
exons typically sometimes the utr
sometimes on the promoter depending on
the the assay design
but uh
what's important here is the copy number
callers if they're calling at exon or
region level they often will be exon
specific
and if conceptually you have again let's
say that exon 4 and exon 5 are deleted
from a panel data you'll only see
you'll get two different variants in the
output a call that exon 4 is a copy
number
loss and that call that exon 5 has the
copy number loss but there'll be two
separate variants rather than one as you
get from a whole genome sequencing
and so qci handles that
automatically for you if the variants
are
adjacent in the gene it'll automatically
determine what the corresponding actual
biological
deletion would be and likewise indicate
exon four to five
deletion or amplification whatever
may be appropriate
so it sort of coalesces adjacent exons
for you so then you don't have to do
extra work in producing your final
reports
for instance or or
do that work yourself it sort of takes
some of that burden of that increased
resolution um
from you so by automatically
grouping adjacent
exons that are deleted or amplified
together
the next part here is that pathogenic
classification which again is done
automatically based on the current
available evidence to qci and it's done
again with full transparency
so
many good clingen uh
slides in the paper and so forth on the
cmv
guidelines
uh so i won't go into depth today but it
just in the interest of time
there are some core differences so it
does have the benign pathogenic
categorization but instead of the acmg
guidelines that have these different
levels of supporting evidence you know
from very strong or strong or moderate
so on supporting
instead the cmv guidelines use a points
based system so for different criteria
here for example it's a
single to multi-exon deletion in that
established haploid sufficient gene in
this case a dmd variant we're looking at
it disrupts the reading frame is
predicted to undergo nonsense media's
decay
that's in these guidelines criteria to
e6 and that gets point uh 0.9 points
for example
you the way they work is you sum up the
points over all the different criteria
that are applicable
and that overall sum is then mapped into
the category of pathogenicity so qci
does this automatically for you
we already know for example um all the
different structures of these genes and
determine you know whether a particular
deletion you observe uh
is in the utr versus exonic or is it uh
exon that matters does it undergo does
it cause uh nonsense immediate decay or
not you know is it in a haploid
sufficient
or loss of function gene and what that
gene is uh we sort of use both clingen's
curation but also supplement that based
on the kaiju knowledge base and the
curation we've we've done as well
so it's all done automatically to apply
those guidelines to create the the sum
and that also is available
beyond this assessment section
in the computed classification at the
top uh you can sort of just click on
that little eye icon and you get this
view on the right this sort of likewise
summarizes that that evidence
uh it's important to note that qci's
interpret is a clinical decision support
tool
so uh it shows you the evidence you can
go the bibliography see additional
literature evidence and the different
criteria it specifies in line like it's
uh you know
in this case the
muscular dystrophy gene is that known to
be haploin sufficient for clingy and
that's why it
puts that in line
in the explanation
but since this clinical decision to
support although we provide the initial
classification
you have complete
liberty to adjust it as you see fit
based on your own expert judgment and
review
so you can either use the classification
or set the assessment as is based on
your view you can add a rationale on the
right if you have multiple people in the
lab you want to add a note about why you
added a removed criteria
but you can over overall set the
assessment based on and set a comment
summarizing the evidence that you
led to your final assessment there
and can also indicate through
reportability where on the report it
goes is it been assessed you don't want
to put on the report or is it been
assessed the secondary finding for
example or is it a uh
you know a reportable finding that
should go in the top of the report so to
speak
so just go into a little more depth
about cmvs with curated literature
evidence
again what we call variant findings
we want to make sure that you can
readily see
which of the many cmds you may have in
the case uh have literature evidence um
and the way we do this is through
uh this variant table you see on the
bottom right here which lists all the
variants and the default sorts them
based on uh
pathogenicity for example
and so uh
the varying findings in this although in
this case i think it's sorted by varying
findings so verb findings uh column
indicates whether the kaijan knowledge
base has
evidence specific to that particular
variant that's shown each each row here
is a different variant so in this case
it may be a
multi-exon
deletion in duchenne musculature regime
that was detected in the ngs assay it
shows that there's 17 different pieces
of evidence specific to that
particular alteration
we also have a
second icon here which is this little
blue plus that indicates there's what we
call additional so to speak relevant
finding so we're trying to make a
distinction here between equivalent
pretty much the same
alteration that you observed in your
patient case and other
cvs that
overlap clearly but
may require a little more review to
determine if they're relevant for your
case i'll show you how that's done
in a moment here
but to explain how uh you determine
whether some variant is
relevant or equivalent um
basically each variant uh the variant
you have in your patient sample which
has a
leftmost chromosomal
position and a rightmost chromosomal
position
and if it's coalesced it includes the
inferred intronic region in between
compare that to the cmv variant from the
literature of the same type like
comparing deletions to deletions or
amplifications amplifications that's
what i mean by type
uh and that
what we've done in our curation of the
cmvs from the literature likewise i
identified the chromosomal ranges for
them and so
uh conceptually what we
use is a similarity score that takes the
base pairs that are in the intersection
of those two ranges
use the variant in your case and the
variant in the literature finding
into account and divide that by the
outermost uh
leftmost position and right most
position of the union
of them and that gives you a what we
call a similarity score
uh if there are identical left and right
endpoints on the chromosome they'll
obviously have a 100 similarity
uh if they're not identical you can see
in these
bottom right here there's there's three
other patterns of you know
the the
curated c cnv from the literature
overlapping the cmv in your patient
sample
uh
containing it or within it or you know
overlapping it on five prime or three
prime end those also can give you
similarity scores uh
in this case in 30 all 50 percent so
beyond the similarity score we also
provide the span type uh and you'll see
in the bibliography feature this helps
you review some of these variants that
we call relevant because there are
contains or within or overlap
whereas equivalent of what we say if 90
if the similar score is 90 or higher
that's considered
equivalent
for our purposes
so uh in the bibliography features
alluded to there are um
these literature references and we'll
show you a demo in a moment here
and give you a more of a feel for how
this all works but
in the bibliography feature when you
click the view view bibliography to see
the kaijun curated supporting
literature and other sources appropriate
for the particular variant you're
looking at
what we do is provide not only the
source article and what we call our
variant finding which you know based on
the particular article may indicate
which particular axon range was deleted
as a germline versus a tumor deletion
for instance a particular disease
association
whatever they're all they're all in
details there
which we do for all findings the small
nucleotide iron findings for example two
uh this this particular case happens to
also be an hdmd and so it has this
fellationb node as well
but there's a massive amount of evidence
we curate uh beyond what is in hdmd as
well i should know
and so
what's
provided here is this cmv criteria
filter on the top right
so that lets you uh further narrow if
you're let's say there's only relevant
findings there's no so to speak
equivalent findings
that gives you a little more
fine-grained means to identify which
articles have
evidence for a similar
experience in a case
where maybe that
your the variant you have in your sample
uh covers it you know sort of is larger
than it or is within it it's sort of
smaller than it or overlaps in the five
time or three primes so it's a quick way
to drill into that literature some of
these various uh quite a bit of
literature on them uh particularly uh
right some of the cancer variants and
variants like dmv have been well studied
and well reported on for for a while
also in the ui we provide a means to not
only see the similarity score and at a
glance understand which which ones
appear to be essentially equivalent
versus uh relevant
um you can click on these links to see
in the genome browser that the same view
so i won't go into that right now but
did sort of the
the range there lets you see um
essentially are they the same size and
on which end do they they differ
if there's some overlap
as well
so with that i would do is uh
pause here and transfer over to you
martin so you can do a
walk through and give folks a sense of
how the application works in in practice
thank you dan i'm just going to share my
screen
okay thanks dan so over the next several
minutes i'm going to demonstrate how you
can approach the interpretation of cnb
variants in a case using qci interpret
but let's first start by orientating
ourselves as we look at the analysis i
have open here
there are three main pages in the
analysis
the variant list page which i'm showing
right now
and the variant details and the review
and report pages which can be accessed
by clicking on the links at the top of
the page here
the variant list page lists the variants
in the analysis in this main table
and by default the variants are ordered
by their automated pathogenicity
classification
the brain details page
provides supporting evidence for the
selected variants that will help
determine whether you want to assess a
variant or include it in the fine
reports
and the review and report page lists any
variants that have been selected for
reporting and is where the case is
finalized or
the
final case report is produced
and we'll come back to these uh sections
later
so for the purpose of this demonstration
i'm showing the case i'm showing here is
an example of a clinical exome
from an affected nine-year-old female
as indicated in the top of the screen
here
with an undiagnosed disease that is
believed to have a genetic basis
the top summary section is showing in
information for the selected variants
and includes the computed pathogenicity
classification
and by clicking on this information icon
i can quickly see the summary of which
acmg criteria have been triggered to
generate the computer class
classification despairing
the variant table lists variants that
have passed a filter and cascade if one
has been applied when creating the
analysis
and by clicking on the filter settings
feature on the left hand side here i can
see details of the filters that have
been applied to this analysis
and the number of variants that have
passed each step in the filtering
cascade
and there are a number of different
filter types that can be applied to an
analysis so for example here
i'm applying filters to retain high
confidence variants that are not
commonly found in the general population
and are predicted to have a significant
impact on a gene's function in the
context the genetic context of interest
and you can see by applying this filter
cascade i've filtered the number of
variants down from almost 85 000 down to
just over 500 variants that are of
potential interest
if i go back to the main page i can
search this table further on the
specific keywords or criteria to quickly
hone in on variants of potential
interest
and the table also contains information
specific to each variance and this
includes the phenotype associated with
the gene uh the mode of inheritance uh
that is associated with the phenotype
the inferred zygosticity of the variant
and known or inferred functional impacts
of that variance
as well as the population frequency and
the number of variant findings that are
present in the kaiju curated knowledge
base
and there's also a link to hdmd if the
variant is present in that database
which can be opened with a single click
now to begin reviewing this case we can
look at the variance in the main table
and i could start by further filtering
the number of errors in this view by
using the view settings
feature on the right hand side here so
for example if i wanted to start with
variants that were predicted to be
compound heterozygous or if i wanted to
focus on copy number variants that were
pathogenic
i could change the filtering here to do
that
but since the variants are already
ordered by their potential significance
as based on the available data
let's just look at the variance in the
top of this table
the first variant is in baracka1 and is
classified as pathogenic
and although this variant is reported to
be dominated it is for a hereditary
cancer risk
and given that this is a child
the presence of this variant would not
explain a rare genetic disease
so however if this were a case where an
adult this could be a relevant variance
report as a secondary finding which is a
feature that is supported by qci
interpretation
moving on to the next two variants in
the list
both are classified as pathogenic and
both appear to be well studied based on
the large number of findings in the
kaiju and knowledge base
however we can see that both variants
are recessive and both appear to be
heterozygous
so these variants are also not likely to
be relevant for the disease in this
particular case
but now if this was a carrier screening
test then of course these variants would
be relevant to uh reports
next we have a
variant
a multi-exon deletion that impacts exon
76 to 79 of the dmdg
as we can see here
and we can see from the variant findings
that there is a case with a reported
copy number loss of high similarity that
is present in the card in curated
literature
and we can also see by hovering over the
blue cross that there are additional cv
variant references that while of a lower
similarity matching score might also be
relevant to review
and to review this literature we can uh
simply click on the view bibliography
feature here
which will open the bibliography for
this variant
now in the bibliography feature i am
able to feature filters for references
by the type of study in which i'm
interested
and so i've selected chemical cases in
this example
but i can also filter references by the
cb criteria that are matching between
the case variant of the reference
such as the type of overlap between the
case and the reference variants
or i could add a similarity score cut
off to filter the
references
or i could
filter the references to only those for
example that had precise endpoints
reported
i can search for a specific um
publication uh in the in the search box
here or i can filter
the references by the author
and i can also sort the references uh by
similarity scores the default for a cnb
variant but i can also sort those by
author or the date of the publication
and if i really want to quickly hone in
on the
variants that were had a similarity
match above 90 percent i could click on
the checkbox here
to show variant specific references only
and that will now filter the references
to only those that have a similarity
score above 90 percent
now if we take a look at the reference i
have selected uh we can see that the
first one listed has a similarity scored
90 as i mentioned
and that this test the test variant
overlaps with the reference variance
however we can see that while the
deletion in the case is the division of
exon 76 to 79
the deletion in the reference is a
deletion of excellence 75-79
so the reference variant impacts uh
additional genomic material in this case
uh details about the genomic regions
impacted by both brains as shown here
and clicking on them will
display the selected region in a gmail
browser
and by clicking on the title of the
publication this will take me to pubmed
where you can view and review the
abstract or open the full text article
if it is available
so now for example if we look in the
next
variant in the list
we can see that this has a lower
similarity score of 49 percent
and
similarly the
varian in the
reference starts at exon 72
so again this variant in the reference
impacts a larger genomic region than the
very case
okay so now i've reviewed some of the
variant
references in the variant table
i can return to the variant list and
looking at the variant details
we can see that dmd
is both recessive and x-linked for the
reported phenotype
and considering that this is a case for
a female and the variant does not appear
to be a homozygous loss
it is unlikely that this dmp mutation
would cause the absurd symptoms
so then moving into the next variant in
the list we see a deletion of the ep300
gene which is also classified as likely
pathogenic in this case
this variant is dominant in a rare
disease gene so might be consistent with
causing the same disease in this case
so if i now uh go into the variant
details
for this variant we can
review additional information that might
be able to help assess experience
the first section to look at is the
assessment section
and we can see here details about the
cmv classification that have been
triggered for this variant
so the variant is obviously impacting a
protein coding gene um with functionally
important elements
both breakpoints are within an
established haploid insufficient gene in
this case ep300
and these breakpoints delete the entire
coding region of the gene so this is
equivalent to a classification of pvs1
and so the resulting score given to this
cnv classification is 0.9
which is equivalent to a likely
pathogenic classification as we can see
here
so if we now go to the bibliography for
this variant
although we don't have a reference which
has a high similarity score uh the
highest being 16 in this case
we can see that the case variant
completely covers the reference variant
and so may have a similar or more
significant impact for this reported
brand
so based on this i could perhaps feel
comfortable about adding this reference
as supporting information for this
variance
and i can do this by clicking on the
reporting status icon here and this will
add the reference to the report if i do
decide to report this variant out
now having added the reference of
interest i can return to the variant
details page
and look for a different additional
evidence that may help further assess
this variance
and if we look in the effect on protein
section we can see here that we have a
link to decipher and this means that if
cipher has an overlapping variant
overlapping with our period of interest
so that means there's potentially
relevant unpublished case evidence
available
so i can click on the disciple link and
this will take me to the disciple
webpage
and i can explore this evidence in more
detail here and we can see that not only
are there a number of other unpublished
case reports for seeing these in this
region but several of these are also
reported to be pathogenic the one shown
here in red
and we can further see that one of the
variants
covers the region of the gene very
similar to the region that we are seeing
in our case and this is also reported to
be pathogenic
so having reviewed this evidence in some
detail i can now go back to
qci
and here i can now explore additional
resources for the the gene of interest
so by clicking on the link here i see i
can have
a link outside htmd or omin or gene
reviews
and after perhaps concluding that the
variance phenotypic spectrum is
consistent with the suspected diagnosis
i can now confirm that
i can now confirm the assessment and set
the final assessment of experience so i
can set this as
being likely pathogenic and reportable
and i can do that by clicking the set
assessment button
and here i have the option to add a
comment to describe the interpretation
and this will update the assessment
so
now that i've added the assessment i can
go back to the variant list
and we can see now that the spirit has
been
reported out or will be included on the
final report
now at this point i could continue to
review additional variance in the case
but once i'm satisfied with the
assessments i can then go to the review
and report page
and
from here
i have a number of options
i can choose to directly sign out the
case
or i could change the state of the case
to flag it for additional review or
flag it for
final approval by the laboratory
director if needed
and finally i could also generate a
preview of the report so this clicking
on this button will generate a pdf
version of the find report if i wanted
to do so
so with that final step i will end this
demonstration and hopefully that has
given you a good sense of how the new
cnv interpretation capabilities and
content that qci interpret provides can
be used in your very interpretation
workflows
uh thank you for your attention and uh
back over to you dan
thanks martin
great so i just like to summarize sort
of what we shared today uh with you it's
sort of
first and foremost the qci interpret
provides a scalable standardized with a
guideline streamlined uh
next-generation sequencing
interpretation reporting tool
and what really sets it apart is this
up-to-date integrated evidence that's
constantly curated by the kaijan
scientific team
that keeps
your ability to understand what's uh
clinically significant or actual uh
constantly up to date and what we
highlight in today's webinar was really
the support qci interpret has for exon
level cnv interpretation it's a lot more
uh
next-generation sequencing secondary
analysis pipelines are detecting
and the content uh as well as the
guidelines here really helps to put in
the biological perspective so it enables
you to quickly triage exon level cnvs
with the
automated
acmg cmv classification guidelines
it should say not only exon level but
gene level it also supports cytogenetic
level cmds if you happen to have those
in your vcf as well
to martin showed it sort of gives you a
means to uh see if there's unpublished
evidence of similar variants and sources
such as decipher and it should note that
those links only show up when there is
evidence for the same similar variant
overlapping varian and decipher for
example only provide those links in
those cases
to streamline your review and then uh
all this integrated literature we have
over 60 000 articles or variant
references
that
uh refer to case studies of
reported cmvs
and that lets you quickly identify which
of the cnvs you have even if there are
variants of uncertain significance have
been reported in published cases in the
literature both uh through the hdmv
integrated content we provide in kaijin
clinical insight interpret
as well as for
tens of thousands of reports that the
kaijan scientific team has also curated
beyond that
and so that enables you to
build up your
case
for assessing a variant of pathogenic
based on both
the acmg guidelines and the curated
evidence that's integrated as well
so with that i'd like to thank you for
your attention and take any questions
great thank you martin and dan for the
interesting presentation and
demonstration so we have about five
minutes left and we can use this time to
answer a few questions that have come in
if you have any questions for the
speakers again please use that q and a
panel and if we don't get to your
question today we will follow up with
you by email
so the first question that we have is
how is the copy number content curated
so
there's um
two two approaches there one is hdmd
where uh one of those things we do is uh
hdmd is another product uh kaijan
provides which
is a database of variants that authors
claim or disease-causing disease
associated so the hdmd team curates the
literature for those
disease-causing mutations and compiles
the database of those
many of those articles were older and so
they didn't necessarily have any genomic
coordinates so one of the things we did
for the hmd content is is help translate
review and translate many of those
references to genomic coordinates which
are necessary to match to
your next generation sequencing data
that likewise comes in in chromosomal
position range or genomic coordinates
that's a good amount of the content a
large amount of content also comes
through kaijan's uh continuous
duration of literature so
one of the things
hydrogen team does is on a daily basis
it screens all the newly published
articles
for
those that refer to
commonly tested genes of interest
hundreds and hundreds of routinely
tested
hereditary
genes as well as all the somatic uh
genes that are clinically um relevant
and as part of that process of
you know whenever articles found there's
different protocols that it can go
through but uh one of the things we do
is try to also index variants of
uncertain significance
um
in these articles and when we
gather those as well
we
include
not just the reference but
for reference articles that talk about
exon deletions and
other kinds of copy number alterations
we map those uh to the gene they very
validate that the
gene uh exon numbering is consistent
with the current gene transcript so to
speak so that we can then get it to
genomic coordinates
and then genomic coordinates that
enables us to
um
match within the application your your
user data or so speak or the genomic
data you upload
to those those alterations so we have
multiple both the curation tool process
to review that also called the assurance
along the way is to ensure that
we
match the so to speak the nomenclature
used in these articles which can be very
variable sometimes they refer to
exons or sometimes they're referred to
ranges in genomic coordinates
not
very consistent use of hgbs for cnv
nomenclature yet in the literature and
so we take care of all that complexity
and our curation processes and protocols
to provide a a
quite comprehensive view of what's known
in the literature
great thank you dan
i think we have time for one more
question
um our last one is does this include
content relevant for cancer panels
so
um
the the
two types of cancer panels uh for
hereditary cancer uh certainly so
hereditary cancer looking at
a risk for retro cancer which many cases
run through qci uh are used to assess
uh copy number variation and like brocco
one and two can account for collectively
maybe uh
well for 10 percent of the disease
burden
so increases the diagnostic yield for
rhetoric cancer to look at copy number
variation
uh it's certainly relevant uh they're
pretty much actually um
on any particular indication so far
disease area where copy number doesn't
play a role and it's sort of a ballpark
it can you know sometimes
be 40 for some neurological disorders in
terms of uh
contributing to disease uh burden on a
genetic basis uh sometimes it's a bit
lower but
the key thing is copy number is relevant
across the the genome
also for rhetoric cancer for for somatic
cancer
the
we do curation for somatic cancer as
well it's it's not the focus here the
guidelines are focused on germline or
hereditary uh disease interpretation
typically in the um
clinical epsom context but also
appropriate for for panels
for tumor samples qci also supports
interpretation of them
we have a different protocols that focus
on um
[Music]
over expression of genes consistent with
copy number amplification for example
that will be picked up if you run a
cancer sample through qci
and there's appropriate
copy number uh evidence in that context
uh so the bibliography in qci will show
information if you're looking at a
pediatric tumor sample for example uh
the the uh
uh and you have a deletion in there
it'll show you whatever evidence we have
in in that um it but generally it will
be in a a heritage disease context not a
somatic context and our focus really is
uh has been um
for the copy number content
uh on germline copy number variation but
the qci interpret
product supports both and we get cup
numbers from a variety of other sources
for somatic interpretation as well
thank you we're now reaching the top of
the hour
i want to take a minute to thank our
speakers
martin and dan for taking the time to
present this for us today i also want to
thank the audience for your attention
this concludes today's session on
overcoming challenges of copy number
variant interpretation with qci
interpret which was presented by dr
martin jones and dr dan richards
we look forward to seeing you in another
kyogen digital insights webinar soon
thank you and i hope you have a good
rest of your day
you